the 2007 film zodiac is based on a
mysterious california criminal in the
60s and 70s but interestingly leaves
certain crime scenes out of the movie
like the first incident which took place
in december of 1968 on lake hermann road
indonesia
the movie simply opens with the second
confirmed case the july 4th 1969 ordeal
in blue rock springs but in each crime
scene that follows we only see certain
details about the zodiac
this isn't just done to build suspense
and make the movie scary
there is a specific reason that director
david fincher held back information the
way that he did
this was the director's first foray into
non-fiction and given the ongoing nature
of the case he wanted to make the movie
as accurate as possible so the
motivation for every zodiac appearance
was to base it off the testimony of
surviving witnesses the lake hermann
road shooting had no survivors and so
was mentioned but never shown in the
movie the blue rock springs affair had
one survivor and the zodiac is shown
covered in shadow with a light shining
in our faces to fit the circumstances of
that july 4th night
the lake berryessa stabbing in september
of that year also had a survivor and we
see the zodiac dressed up to hide his
identity as described by the living
victim and the presidio heights
occurrence doesn't give the viewer any
information that the kids who called in
the felony wouldn't have been able to
see for themselves
this was done to ensure that the
filmmakers were sticking to the truth
the first confirmed victims were a
couple who both died in 1968 so the
filmmakers don't really have an account
of the events
so in order to create the scene on film
they would have had to make stuff up to
see other examples of the painstaking
dedication to accuracy and the meaning
behind some of the many posters that
appear
stick around to the end of this video
welcome to things you missed i believe
this is the first non-fiction episode of
things you missed the only partial
exception would be the conjuring
franchise movies which are still
fictional stories but they are based on
real life characters
so far zodiac is the only movie i've
covered that adapts only real life
events
the obvious reason is that this is a
horror channel and it's often considered
to be rude to turn someone's real life
horrors into popcorn cinema but zodiac
does an excellent job of being accurate
respectful and still having kills that
are very suspenseful and scary
not many people have basements in
california
i do in fact it does
much better than many fictional horror
movies i mean i'm not gonna name any
names not gonna
name the turning i'm not gonna name
black christmas 2019
not gonna name countdown definitely not
gonna name breitbart
the depictions of the zodiac weren't the
only aspects where extreme attention to
accuracy was paid
the opening logos of the film are
reminiscent of the logos used by those
studios during the 60s complete with
dust and scratches on the film to make
it feel as if we're watching an old
movie the wardrobe department used all
available information to recreate what
each victim was wearing and i quickly
figured this out throughout the movie
all of the newspapers seen on camera are
real prints from the zodiac
investigation the far
corner there's a stack of the day's
newspaper to the san francisco chronicle
and there is in the in the movie too
you could walk onto the set pick up like
the third newspaper from a stack of 20
at the bottom
open up to page 37 and read the article
that was in the chronicle that day
the production had access to information
that the general public did not so it's
not always obvious how much care was
taken to get these things right
but one scene where it was obvious was
the infamous melvin bellai broadcast
where the zodiac demanded that the
prominent attorney appear on the talk
show am san francisco
fincher's approach was not just to make
an entertaining movie but also to create
a competent piece of journalism after
reading the script which is based on the
main character robert grey smith's book
which we can actually see on the shelves
in the latter half of the movie fincher
wanted to go
even deeper and meets the surviving
victims in the investigation for the
purposes of maintaining authenticity and
journalistic integrity
in a way the movie in its pursuit of
getting all the little details right
became the ultimate knowledge database
for details about the case as we see in
the film part of the obstacle that
prevented the case from being solved was
that you had several different police
departments with jurisdiction over
certain areas who didn't always
communicate and share the info with each
other as well as they could have the
next one isn't necessarily a thing you
missed in the movie but it's definitely
something that you wouldn't know if you
had just watched the movie we see at the
end of the aftermath
in 2004 the san francisco police
department deactivated their zodiac
investigation the movie zodiac was
released on march 2nd
2007 and that same month the case was
reopened in san francisco where it
remains open
today if you are curious the biggest
update came in 2018 where some of the
letters sent into the newspapers were
sent to a lab where it was thought that
some new forensic testing could match
the dna from the back of the stamps
however as of 2020
still no results have been reported i do
find it somewhat ironic that a movie
would be what theoretically reopened the
case in san francisco because one of the
theories about zodiac was that he was a
big fan of movies and pop culture
leading the detectives at one point to
go after a suspect named rick marshall
who worked at movie theaters on two
separate occasions
the zodiac killer is obsessed with
movies he recorded his murders on film
i tried to tell the police but they
wouldn't follow through on it what
what no no i i wasn't alive in the 60s
what i swear it is at one point
suggested that the zodiac symbol could
be related to the crosshair imagery seen
in a film leader and
greysmith makes a connection in which
one of zodiac ciphers appears to
reference a film called the most
dangerous game in which a hunter goes
after humans for sports
zodiac is also rich with cinema
references most notably to one in 1971
action flick called the dirty harry
this is about a movie about a couple of
killers harry callahan
and a homicidal maniac
the one with the badge is harry it's
loosely based on the zodiac murders with
an antagonist named scorpio which is one
of the 12 zodiac signs who sends threats
to the san francisco chronicle there are
so
many connections here i hope that the
use of a crosshair symbol was not lost
on you dirty harry also takes place in
san francisco and in a zodiac featurette
the screenwriter james vanderbilt
suggests that dirty harry was actually
based on detective dave toski
the real life version of the mark
ruffalo character
mark was able to sort of bring that
wonderful humanity
that you don't expect to find in the guy
who bullet was based
on and dirty harry was based on and the
diner where toski likes to eat in zodiac
is called callahan's diner
harry callahan and the movie that tosky
goes to see where he first meets robert
greysmith
dirty harry a poster can be seen as he
exits the cinema
then at the last scene that grey smith
and tosky share together in callahan's
diner there's
this line just because you can't prove
it doesn't mean it's not true
easy dirty harry there would be even
more significant movie references in
zodiac that the zodiac himself would
probably be proud of but those wouldn't
be the only connections and things you
missed
yet to come
in robert gray smith's book he describes
the crimes in great detail but doesn't
really talk about his personal life or
the reason he becomes so obsessed with
the case
in the movie we see the sad evolution of
his personal life and if you're paying
close attention there is a suggestion
about why he becomes so fascinated with
zodiac
it seems that greysmith or at least the
movie version of greysmith may have been
a crime movie buff here we see a poster
in his living room for alfred
hitchcock's the wrong man
nearby is a poster of john houston's the
asphalt jungle behind the couch is a
poster for the 1955 crime flick i died a
thousand times
by the door he's got a poster for the
1955 movie illegal
as we know one of grace smith's
strongest assets isn't his movie
knowledge but his
knowledge of books by the phone is a
series of book covers for the original
james bond stories by ian fleming which
i realize may fall more under action but
they definitely still have
aspects of the crime genre at one point
robert suggests the idea of tracking
books that zodiac may have used to
develop the code used in deciphers
i started thinking that if you can track
these books then maybe you can track the
man
we've seen this tactic used once before
in a crime movie directed by david
fincher and the crime i'm referring to
is not stealing the idea for an 800
billion dollar website i'm talking about
it's the seven night where we see
detective somerset who similarly tries
to solve a themed serial killer case by
using library records
ask yourself hey wait wait what would he
study to do the things he's done
what was it just now dr ripper francis
where are we going library obviously
that came out before zodiac but zodiac
is based on events that happened
before so se7en so i wonder if fincher
was already an enthusiast of the zodiac
case before he made the 7n and that's
what inspired him to put in that plot
point supposedly fincher was the first
name that they went to about directing
zodiac because he had already made the
definitive serial killer film there's
also a possible reference to another
fincher film a much
sillier one let's roll the club
right up ah now a question of vatican
has i passed on giving the ass or the
crotch
this can't be a coincidence right
it can't be a coincidence well there's
one thing that's definitely not a
coincidence in this
in the background of the scene at the
police station there's a cameo
appearance from brian c hartnell the
real-life survivor of the lake berryessa
attack who can be seen as an adult in
the documentary this is the zodiac vegan
another possible pattern in the zodiac
case that gets brought up in the film
and book is that each of the attacks
that zodiac has proven his involvement
in have some kind of connection to a
body of water
lake hermann road blue rock springs lake
berryessa which was actually a reservoir
but still water and then
washington and cherry the weakest
example of the bunch so there are also
aquatic references in the movie like
grace smith's favorite adult beverage
being something called aqua velva the
first shot of the film looking out over
the water and a poster in the movie
theater organist house for
key largo a crime slash noir movie set
next to the ocean in key largo florida
as i mentioned before one of the
frustrating parts of this case was that
years and years would go by where
nothing new would happen and i think
this stagnation is symbolized perfectly
when greysmith eventually goes to visit
his old pal
paul avery and finds him in the middle
of a game of pong instead of pausing it
the game continues to run with neither
side making a move the entire time
the film's ending like the real case
doesn't offer much closure to the plot
but i find that the film does give
closure for a couple of the characters
greysmith at one point tells his wife
that it'll be over when he's able to
look the zodiac in the eye and know that
it's him
in the book the hardware store scene is
a mission to try to gather more
information about arthur lee allen
primarily to get a real handwriting
sample when he doesn't suspect it but in
the movie
all we see is the eye contact between
grey smith and allen the smile
slowly disappearing from his face as he
realizes
who this visitor is the very last scene
provides closure for another character
and it brings the entire movie full
circle the first character to appear on
screen was
mike majeau and 22 years later after
pointing out the man that forever
changed his life he would be the last
character to appear before
a cut to black the end credits music is
the same music that they listened to on
the radio that night
while we may never know for sure who the
zodiac killer was
this scene tells us that for the oldest
confirmed survivor the case was closed
but as one case closes another one
opens here on things you missed because
in the next episode i'll be wrapping up
my series of david fincher analyses with
my personal favorite
sorry zuck it's gone girl remember to
subscribe to cz's world for new horrors
every week ring the death bell for
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one
assuming we stay inside